[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the break room everybody
it's our daily nerdy news show it talks
about everything you need to know live
from New Rockstar's actual break room
here maybe in Los Angeles uh uh today we
are just talking about phase five okay
phase four wrapped we even got the
epilogue for phase four with the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
wrap so we're looking forward
specifically to the next 18 months phase
five for the MCU with me to do that
today an esteemed panel we've got koi
uh I'm here with one of my favorite
people to do panels with for the first
time in years
later yes welcome back two days in a row
we're making a habit out of it welcome
Hector and of course Jessica yeah with
my best friend
we can't even get this correct okay yeah
our chemistry is palpable
um and and speaking of that chemistry if
you want to witness that in person oh
yeah and you're going to be in the Los
Angeles area this weekend we're going to
be doing the break room live at La
Comic-Con in downtown Los Angeles
um Sunday morning 10 30 a.m if you're
around come see us Jessica and myself
will be there tell me back till Brandon
Barrick Eric Voss is going to be in town
uh doing it
um the boss Master himself
um maybe some other familiar faces come
by and say hey we'd love to see you
either Corey Hector you guys going to
L.A I got a panel at 11 so 10 to 10 45
I'll be you oh I got you okay yeah thank
you we'd love to have I think I'm doing
stuff on Sunday but I also be at La
Comic Con which is so exciting well oh
my god well I'll be in there there's
just all like flash by like yeah yeah
ships passing in the night so hey um
come to our panel come to their panels
come to everybody's panels it'll be
great
um okay we're gonna no headlines today
partly because we want to talk about
this topic and partly because
um there's no news
sometimes sometimes it'd be like that it
does sometimes it does be like that
um all right so right phase four is over
we're looking forward to phase five
which is kicking off in just a couple
months in February of next year
um and so what we're gonna do this
episode is we're going to go through all
five films in Phase five five for five
uh we're gonna talk about everything we
know about them and then later in this
episode each of us is going to give our
rankings pre-rankings for what we think
how how we think those movies are going
to be and that now we'll have to the
rankings are a mix of like what we think
is going to be the best what we think is
going to be the most impactful you know
Jessica is using that as one of her main
messages I said impactful not my
favorite if I had to do it in what I'm
gonna like favorite my bottom would be
at the top
yes it's very confusing what's going in
you've changed the game
I like certain actors a lot and I love
different stories a lot but I think the
ones that are going to impact phase six
are I made a list with this but this was
the challenge of like it's not just what
what is going to be you think your
personal favorite it's what you think is
going to be the overall best quality
impactful probably most award-winning
all of that kind of thing most highest
Rotten Tomatoes critics score that kind
of thing on board
Marty's pick number one yeah
in 10 years when we look back at these
movies right what we'll be like oh well
that
um okay so we're gonna go through the
five films right now and again this this
is a short phase this starts next year
and just runs through the the first half
of 2024 even so we get five movies and a
handful of Disney plus series We're not
gonna be talking about the series we're
focusing on the the films we might
mention the series and how they'll be
impacted by the films but um so to begin
February kind of two months away we're
getting Ant-Man of the Lost quantumania
um the only film in this list that we've
had an official trailer yeah and ah what
a trailer uh awesome trailer for it
um we know Kang is the main villain in
it presumably right he's featured
prominently in the trailer yep yep
um maybe the beginning of kind of the
King
Dynasty storyline that we know will pay
off is Modoc in this one is he allegedly
in this one yeah yes so it's there's two
almost villains and we don't know we
don't know what Monarch's doing maybe
he's a good guy maybe this is before
he's bad maybe I want to throw this out
there I don't know if this is a third
villain or if this is part of Modoc or
what the rumors are but I remember years
ago actress Evangeline Lilly posted a
photo of like the cover of the script
for Ant-Man 3 and she was like tagging
the actors in the film and she was
putting like hashtag Ant-Man hashtag
wasp hashtag Corey stole who played
Darren cross in the first element you
also remember he like disintegrated into
the quantum realm and we thought he died
so he could totally she posted that I
freaked out because I was like no one's
picked up on this yet no one said hang
on a minute hang on what what does she
mean by hashtag Corey stole Corey does
not have an Instagram so she couldn't
tag him so she put hashtag did she
accidentally sleep in the movie they
brought him back he's gonna be bearded
so he's the potential that's what I'm
saying yeah that's also potential and
also you don't know who Bill Murray is
and there's even been maybe that's who
Hank uh or Jenny Van Dyne married was
yeah he's the most important okay don't
you dare get in your hand
um yeah and there's even been there's
been some rumors Corey still could be
playing Modoc in some weird oh
so there's Maybe
more than Kane
yes
and we haven't speculated on this show
and in some other places right maybe the
end of Scott Lang in this film there's
definitely this feels like the most
dangerous Ant-Man film potentially it's
just the tone of that trailer could be a
little heavier a little bit more serious
little higher Stakes the Next Generation
yes of ant themed hero also we've had a
lot of Legacy characters introduced we
haven't lost a lot of The Originals like
we've you know we've got four of the
father Steve right or he's died but
retired Steve Rogers Hawkeye's still in
play Tony's out Thor's still in play
Hawkeye still in play well Clinton was
higher but like Widow is dead it didn't
feel solid right he's just like at home
so like Ant-Man as a father figure might
be more impactful because he isn't there
as opposed to four who's gonna be more
impactful as a father figure I mean I
can see especially with an older child
like Thor as a father is nurturing
whereas like you're the dad that's like
oh Dad and I think she will have to grow
by losing her father because she seems
to be on the wrong side of the law
Cassie losing Scott actually statured we
might need that Arc and again my my pet
theory is if you want to establish Kang
as a villain of a Thanos level have him
kill Scott Lang
that's the table okay so that's and had
Quantum Mania coming in February the
only one that we've seen a full trailer
for uh we're excited about it we'll get
to our rankings here in a minute but
let's moving on sequentially May of next
year Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. now
this one's kind of fresh on our minds
because we just all watched the holiday
special uh last weekend or or earlier
um uh James Gunn has said this is his
most emotional movie ever
I think Rocket's gonna live I think uh
this could be the end of Peter Quill I
think I think it's the end of both I
thought they both would die oh but I
also okay we talked about this in enzyme
Marvel recently with mt and boss where
we're like yeah mantis is now going to
be taking up the mantle of Star-Lord
because she's technically
related to a star so they uh so it's
like oh taking that mantle or taking it
away from Peter and Peter just moving he
has to exit either it's dying or it's
just him disappearing but I think he's
gonna go and I think rocket has to die
unfortunately because everyone loves him
that's how it goes that's how it goes
that's how it goes you have to be
connected to these people this is when
we were trying to figure out who's gonna
die in wakanda Forever before wakanda
forever dropped and I was like Well it
can't be embarked because we don't have
that close of a connection to him yet so
it had I was like it's either a koye or
it's going to be Angela Bass I think we
keep Rocket and Groot because groot's
already died so that'd be redundancy and
I think rocket is going to be the thing
that the villain has made I I think it's
pretty clear that you know the high
evolutionary created rocket so I think
it if he dies it feels
it feels like more of just an Avenger
like they're avenging him I don't think
he dies I think they feel for their
friend that's been tortured his whole
life and for some reason if they kill
him and that feels lesser I want there
to be a bit of Revenge I want there to
be a journey with him and a Redemption a
Redemption for rocket to feel hole and
if rocket steady doesn't get to feel
whole so I hope that taking out him
makes the whole rocket the first
Guardians of the Galaxy movie he's like
I didn't ask to get made right and then
you bring that all the way to be made
exactly by taking out more and then kill
him at the end no no no no no but you
take out big boy Big Bad Guy what's his
name and uh uh uh High Evolution and
then you take out Peter Quill in the way
and you take out I think nebula and the
more both go Gilmore's already kind of
gone anyways
is not non-existent anymore
not as much I don't think it has as much
pool as rockers
just wants to start wearing shirts and
movies you know what I mean
let me have a burger uh okay so they're
moving into the final we have three
Marvel movies next year the final one
next year July of 2023 the Marvels now
some footage for this has been shown not
publicly just at uh d23 did you see it
okay I've seen it okay uh word on the
street it was excellent footage
can I can I speak to it sure I don't
know if where we were on this but nieta
Casa made Candyman which is I think one
of the best horror movies in this golden
age of horror movies I don't identify as
a horror fan but lately I've been like
oh I get the Merit Justice
[Applause]
I loved it but I would never be like
that was my favorite Horrible no no not
favorite I'm saying it was exceptional
in an age of exceptional like it's shown
me that I like horror because it was so
good when I thought I going into it I
wouldn't enjoy it I'm just saying it's
exceptional in the genre I mean yeah you
can like it thank you
showed me there was a thing that I
didn't expect to like that I'd like and
the visual aesthetic of the film was so
atmospheric and so like profound and
like the performances were great it gave
me all the things I want from a really
good Marvel director because I think the
best comedy directors no horror and vice
versa and I think the best comic book
directors know both because the timing
is so integral that's why you got your
James wands that's why you got your
animation so I'm really excited for his
director the footage was everything I
wanted the first Captain Marvel to be I
will own publicly and I will accept the
scorn Captain Marvel's in my bottom four
Marvel films ever Captain Marvel's not
my jam Captain Marvel made a lot of
money I'm very happy for all the people
that did appease uh it's a character
that I hold very near and dear to my
heart and Brie Larson's an actor I adore
when you put those two things together
and it doesn't land it's extra painful
but everything she's been in outside of
that I've adored her and even when she's
been a guest star as Captain Marvel so I
think the direction was two directors
that were in a different wheelhouse and
the movie feels like it was two
directors making different movies plus
Studio stuff and then it's the only
Marvel movie I think that looks cheap
like the sets look cheap and Jude Law's
twist was not smart uh all of it didn't
work for me I am the most excited for
nietacosta to redeem a character I love
with an actor I love and a Supporting
Cast of people that I fall in love with
this season I from the trailer got all
of that in like two minutes nice
when she smashes down by the theater
that's where I live like literally right
across the street and I was like that's
my theater and then you're like this
place will get away
right uh the Marvels with an S has that
s because we know it's going to have
Carol Danvers obviously Captain Marvel
Kamala Khan
and Monica Rambo superhero name as of
yet unrevealed but Monica Rambo from One
Division yes
um somehow the three of them who as of
right now have never been in the same
room at the same time uh or at least
powered up right like are gonna be on a
journey together so this is some
speculation the plot might kind of
follow a Cree scroll War I bet if it
does we will learn about that in secret
Invasion coming up early next year that
might that that series and that film
might be kind of uh contextually linked
maybe
for this one it has Freaky Friday Vibes
which I think is a great thing to add to
the Marvel Universe because that's such
a common comment take that comic book
the [ __ ] bands or whatever that thing
was that old school Marvel thing is so
like when Wolverine Spider-Man switch
bodies is a good time I want more of
that like I want that playfulness here I
love it and there's some speculation
that maybe every time the neck the the
bands are used they flip bodies and so
they're constantly going from outer
space to New Jersey and back could be
great I don't know that's yeah Lindsay
Lohan has mentioned numerous times how
they're trying to do another Freaky
Friday and same with Jamie Lee Curtis is
down but I wonder if Disney's like we
can't do it because
now uh and they also just made Hocus
Pocus 2.
upgrade and Venom came out the same year
starting almost twice and Venom
basically the same person
okay
To That actor he's very good he's not
Tom Hardy it's not Tom Hardy
it's hot
he's great in Spider-Man
it sounds like a a holiday Spider-Man
homecoming Tom tardy excellent
okay now moving into uh the last two
films in Phase five beginning or may of
2024 Captain America New World Order
um excited for this uh we know casting
and that's about it for this but it's a
big casting you know uh the leader Tim
Blake Nelson is coming back Awesome from
The Universal uh Incredible Hulk film
yeah from 2008 yeah yes Carl lumbly last
seen in Falcon Winter Soldier will be
coming back Harrison Ford will be
playing Thunderbolt Ross has been
confirmed I believe yeah yeah we did it
yeah we did an episode
that is insane uh William Hurt uh he
will be stepping into the shoes of uh
William Hurt who played that character
across multiple films yeah um and we
assume we'll be red hulking out at some
point maybe in this movie
um Sabra the the name of that actress uh
I didn't write down but um that
character the Israeli superhero will be
appearing and Danny Ramirez who was
teased in um is becoming the new
Falconer Soldier and of course there's
not saying
um we assume uh Anthony Mackey's yeah he
was on stage he'll be in yeah
and are you sure and now not to step on
the next film but we've kind of assumed
Sebastian Stan might be in this movie
maybe not we don't know posters a little
leading Oh wait we're talking about I
thought we went to the next one no this
is
it could be after he's done his first
full mission as cap like see he
accomplishes a thing and then we find
out where Bucky's been as a choice to
lead into like maybe they're because I
he's the most therapized of all of them
we actually saw him in therapy yeah I
there has to be a reason to set up what
happens in Thunderbolts I'd love to see
that teased at the end of this new world
order so it'd be a great way to use a
post-credit scene in a way that doesn't
feel just like that's interesting
because I was singing Thunderbolts would
actually timeline wise take place before
but we'd see it after that movie but it
would take place before that because
it's a very interesting point I've
always assumed that
Thunderbolts was happening before the
next Avengers movie for the reason of
there are no Avengers right I think
we've kind of heard that throughout
phase four like in Spider-Man uh far
from home technically are you gonna be
the next Tony Stark are you in The
Avengers like being asked about that all
these characters are constantly sort of
bringing it up but it's sort of vague
She-Hulk will be an Avenger they're
promising but like there's no real
Avengers compound or or organization or
whatever and I think that Captain
America if something else doesn't before
then will like definitely confirm Sam
Wilson is not only there is no
government sanctioned Avengers there's
no Tony Stark funded Avengers there's no
nothing official and Thunderbolts is the
thing that slides in and goes well now
the government and Contessa Valentina
Allegra de Fontaine and whatever that
group of people including General Ross
himself they're going to officially well
here's our Avengers team it's kind of
like when Norman Osborne
all that kind of thing and I also think
that I don't know if it's uh I hate to
ask can we pull up the graphic for phase
five if possible they're in the TV world
there's no Young Avengers right correct
kick it over into phase six there's some
spaces there's some spaces look before
Avengers the Kang Dynasty there's three
blank slots there I think maybe one of
the TV shows we're gonna get on Disney
plus is Gonna Be Young Avengers and it's
gonna be gonna lay out all of the
characters up to this point that they're
also coming together like in the comics
when there are no official Avengers yeah
I also think we're gonna get some
specials I think we're gonna get a
special for Cassie Lang we might get a
special special presentation special
presentation Adventure we might we might
come back to this later in the show okay
economically it would make sense if it
was a special instead of a series okay
we're counting Bob iger's pennies for
him don't get him started
business we do not know that much about
the plot for this especially we do not
know how much the plot for new world
order right will overlap or not overlap
with the plot for the final film in
Phase five uh July 2024 Thunderbolts
Stanford it happens
what no that was Civil War dude yep do
you think Stanford's gonna happen
Stanford he's talking about the comic
book event that kicked off Civil War
back in 2006 in the Marvel Comics yep
Stamford Connecticut a small town which
they did with crossbones in the film
effectively having him hit the bomb
happen with Scarlet Witch a bad guy who
blew up and a bunch of civilians
including Elementary School died 900
people died and that's what made the
government go we need to stamp down on
this and keep saying drop a bomb he's
used the expression three times
David Harbert who's one of the we're at
some point we're gonna do a Mount
Rushmore of people for uh actors giving
interviews you know d'onofrio's on there
Harbor's on there um what's his name MAF
Gideon
um John Carlos is on there right there
are people they're just actors they're
usually like older not give a [ __ ] uh
actors who've already made their bones
and they're just like I'm gonna say
crazy stuff
um David Harbor has said that like this
movie's gonna be awesome and we're gonna
drop a bomb now I love that's a
metaphoric bomb a literal bomb
so Thunderbolts need to have an impetus
and I think that Thunderbolts have to
form and the government is at the ready
like you're implying but I think there
needs to be I think it's going to be
Thunderbolts versus Young Avengers maybe
it happens in New World Order I think
the end of the world order is an event
that occurs or something happens that's
why I think it's first I think something
cap can't stop because remember like in
Winter Soldier when Steve Rogers and
Bucky and or Steve Rogers was fighting
Bucky and Sam Wilson was there and they
saved shield from Hydra but they still
sank three helicopters like the
government could have looked at that and
gone what are we doing what are we doing
maybe World Order will have some similar
third act Sam still saves a day but
yeah maybe you gotta have it because
he's unsanctioned I guarantee Sam is not
gonna be working for the government the
way we've seen him through Falconer
soldiers he usually doesn't I can see
the result exactly he represents America
not the government which is when her
soldier's whole point so I could see
something happening in the end of the
world order that establishes the
government doesn't sanction Avengers
they have their own and that could also
be something that would require a bomb
of sorts and you know these two films uh
New World Order and Thunderbolts are two
months apart right and we haven't seen
none of phase four and we might Circle
back and talk a little bit about phase
four but like none of phase four the
films were not connected or necessarily
building on one I guess Multiverse and
Madness and no way home certainly had
some overlap but like the those two
doctor strangers didn't necessarily feel
like the exact same guy right
um whereas we don't know yet but these
two films could be Infinity war in
game-esque right like two parts of of a
single story right yeah um with slightly
different casts and so again recap of
the Thunderbolts uh we know a cast we've
seen a cool poster uh we know
Sebastian's Bucky we know
um Elena beloved uh we know Red Guardian
David Harbor
semi truck is roller skate is better in
that movie than ghost but wouldn't oh
wow wow
and I like that actor she's really good
but anyways okay and then uh Taskmaster
yeah presumably the same Taskmaster we
saw in Black Widow the actress did like
was there or did speak on it that she's
going to be in the film as Taskmaster
but again all this is so early and it's
um I just want to throw this out there
too I don't know if we've seen all the
characters oh there's definitely gaps
come on there's gaps in the poster I
think that really famously for a
Thunderbolts or kind of like a bad guy
Avengers team you gotta have a Hulk I
think about Abomination on this team but
they didn't want to spoil it because
She-Hulk hadn't ended you see what I'm
saying I think that there's some stuff
that we still are going to get revealed
I think Zemo gets uh some play I think
zemo's gonna be in the movie because
he's not in the movie nope yeah
well when the Thunderbolts split up I
think that's when zemo's going to be
taking uh valentina's position
I think they have to I think zemo's
still bad and I want him to still be
going back I think that they're going to
introduce a character named citizen V
and everybody's gonna be like oh this is
a new Marvel character because Kevin
feige said there are characters in The
Thunderbolts movie new characters we
haven't even seen yet I think he's being
not to borrow your name koi I think he's
lying and being like you're going to
meet a new character here's citizen V
they're going to put him in a trailer
just like when Sebastian Stan was the
Winter Soldier in those early trailers
and it took a few trailers for the thing
to come off and for him to go Bucky yeah
him go Who the hell's Bucky I think
they're gonna try to do a similar thing
with Zemo because in the comic books
Zemo was citizen V and it wasn't until
the end of the first issue very famously
and people had no idea all of the
previews up to that issue it was like
here's a new team of characters new team
of superheroes you know because guys we
thought they were good guys and at the
end of the first issue citizen V takes
off his mask and it's helmetzemo yep and
and all the other characters are also
bad guys in Disguise and they're like
we're actually all bad guys for real but
when I think that they're going to try
to do a version of that in this movie
this time I know I think Thunderbolts
are good people because they've all had
Redemption arcs that are actively
working to be better and they're sent in
the wrong mission
and I think that's going to be the the
position throughout the movie is gonna
be like yeah we're trying to be good I
think that's being too close to Suicide
Squad is being like we're doing good I
think one is ultimately gonna switch and
I want it to be us agent so bad yeah I
want him to reveal himself as a demon
monster that you forget I did forget
John Walker Johnny mayonnaise as we
affected on this show pretty boy great
actor son of ego
in real life maybe in Canon we don't
know
okay real quick we are going to now that
we've covered these five films and kind
of everything we know about them and
some fun theories we think about the
plots we each of us are going to give
our rankings for what we think uh how
this phase is going to turn out but real
quick we want to shout out a couple
things first off we want to shout out
our friends over at the epic hero shop
have this uh cool vest
um they call it a convex it's the best
you could wear to a con can you read it
uh from here no no it's it's in like
Aura bash and wakandan and all these
different um Elvish fictional there you
go
um
the the goal of this vest is you buy
this and you cover it with your favorite
pins and patches and all you express all
your fandoms we are going to be giving
away we're going to cover this bad boy
with pins and patches and then we're
going to be giving this guy away click
the link in this video's description uh
submit your email and you can enter to
win that exact vest that will have at
least a little bit of mine stink on it I
cannot think of a higher status item at
a Comic-Con than that best I never
thought about it it is status out the
Wazoo baby you walk around with that
thing yeah it depends you'll know people
can be like is that the new rock stars
from you is that is that the best one
yeah and then you can open it and you
can show the signatures of the new
recite staff on the inside
for those that know and you know I use
my bank signature I don't know how to
use a fake signature again wow so
getting checks in Jessica's name um
Millions yeah that best pays for itself
Jessica's sake that's right and then you
just bought them that best speaking of
million dollars we don't want to feel
like a million bucks and you know who's
really helpful for that our friends at
athletic greens I know this time of year
between like holiday meals and travel
and whatever I'm not eating right
um I'm not keeping my vitamin and
nutrient intake where it should be uh so
that's why I lean on our friends at
athletic greens I've got a little travel
pack of their product ag1 right here
this you you just pour this guy in a
little cup of water
I keep mumming when I'm doing a lot of
work I'm gonna do more than four shows a
day I think we just discovered the
secret koi jandro's energy which you
want to figure out for years guys I keep
these on my portable I got a little
extra wide uh mouth water bottle and
carport shake it up for me
they call it it's like nutritional
Insurance because like maybe you have a
maybe a good one day maybe you don't eat
good the next day but you know what
those vitamins and nutrients you got to
get those every day so this like covers
your bases when maybe you're you're
running around town or you you slip up
and you have a cupcake lunch or whatever
right it's the holidays it's the
holidays candy canes have very little
niacin what is this fact uh not a lot of
vitamin D in a yule log that's what I'm
well I'm saying he's not wrong
absolutely so grab yourself crazy one uh
from our friends at athletic greens uh
actually if you click the link in this
video's description go to that URL which
we appreciate it's on screen right now
as well uh because then they know we
sent you and that helps us as well as
helping you uh you also get a free a
year supply of vitamin D which you know
we have uh Christian unpronounceable and
some other folks that um often are super
chatting in from Canada or any of the
northern climbs you know what I mean
maybe you're up in Minnesota
Massachusetts yep or Corey has folks
right it gets dark there in the winter
you're not getting a lot of sunlight you
need your Vitamin D supplements
true
it's dark in Washington too oh good
point yeah like five yeah that's right
none of us you know what even in
Southern California we're not getting
enough Sunshine so okay we're not in
California right right now rumors right
exactly could be in Manitoba some people
say uh in somewhere inside Area 51.
um to make it easy athletic greens again
they'll give you a free one-year supply
of immune supporting vitamin D and five
free travel packs these little guys uh
with your first purchase all you have to
do is visit visit athleticgreens.com
break room again that's
athleticgreens.com breakroom to take
ownership of your health and pick up the
ultimate daily nutritional Insurance
thank you to athletic greens there's no
greens and coffee there can be oh I've
done it it's oh that's that sounds
intense it cancels it out we're going to
roll in our whiteboard oh my goodness in
the second half of this episode we're
going to
um
give our rankings for how we feel like
these phase five films are going to play
out okay
um each of us each of us have pre-ranked
the five films of fight phase five uh in
what we think will be maybe some
combination of importance to the MCU uh
long lasting historical relevance in
quality as as Hector just put it
concisely the best um so we're each
gonna show our top fives in order and
then kind of justify the um uh dashel is
trying to direct us so that we uh
maintain something oh
I was making like Instagram yeah it's
between oh
so we're each going to place our top
fives and I mean we kind of argue about
the placement uh disagree with each
other whatever in the chat let us know
who's getting it right who's getting it
wrong you're gonna go first because you
have the most boring lineup that's
correct uh that was statistically uh how
we decided yeah go second
um okay so okay so I'm leading off now
this is maybe a recently it's going from
one to five or five to one countdown
good point five to one okay uh no
offense I'm doing Marvel's last maybe I
would feel differently if I had seen
that footage of d23 but I just don't
know enough about this movie I'm not as
excited about it again I hope it changes
my mind next I have New World Order
um again maybe maybe you want to get
more information my mind will change
there but I'm I'm my imagination is what
you're saying now okay I have to see it
already and then I have I have
Thunderbolts next and and weirdly I
don't want to spoil anything but I am
one of the more positive people about
Thunderbolts among this lineup okay and
then I have I guess
in quantumania real quick so this is
recency bias is quantumania is the first
one we're getting and again I am heavily
swayed by trailers folks you love those
trailers and Marvel is crushing it on
trailers lately okay thank you Andrew uh
the wakanda forever first trailer
incredible there's Quantum media trailer
John and I in the office multiple times
in the last week have just watched this
trailer and like paused it on certain
frames and just geeked out for like five
minutes have you seen it in 3D I have
not it's very incredible it's very good
I also think as we've kind of mentioned
that um I'm advocating for strange words
you heard it here first specifically in
3D go see it in 3D go see Strange World
3D and maybe you'll catch the trailer
for Quantum so
um again I'm just gonna zoom in on one
of these I think Thunderbolts and why
I'm maybe a little bit more bullish on
it than some other folks we haven't had
a team up movie since end game
really right like this team movie yes
that team up movies correct we've had
doctor strange and Spidey you know but
good point but an actual team putting
together a squad I also think there's a
reason this you know phase five and
phase six are extremely short phases and
and they could have said they're all one
phase right there's a reason they picked
okay Thunderbolts to end phase five I
think some big stuff's gonna happen
there Corey and Hector were kind of just
speculating on some of the craziness
that could be happening between New
World Order and Thunderbolts but I I'm
I'm very excited about this movie don't
let the fact that it's in the middle all
these movies are also very positive for
me I don't know will you hear me will
you hear me a bunch yes okay I got the
second least problematic
quite problematic
[Applause]
controversial uh the less the most
excitable list you have the most maybe
you two have the most maybe realistic
yeah
we're starting from number five yes
don't look at me
six correct I put it yeah no no you're
good
um I did Thunderbolts
because I think Thunderbolts and Captain
America New World Order are in the same
kind of vein of like military government
situation so which one's gonna be more
important to us uh and that's why I put
thunderbolts at the bottom I think it's
gonna be very fun though regard this
does not reflect which ones I'm most
excited Jessica
thunderbolts at the beginning that if
this was based on like personal opinion
yeah that would have been your number
one and then this would have been my
number two wow great
um you guys know I love the marbles uh I
think the marbles are great too but I
just think right now we're focusing on a
different world and we're getting ready
for Kang and I don't think we're gonna
get that in the Marvels
um sorry I have to keep looking back at
my list because I forget how the order I
went guards of the Galaxy is my third
um and after conversation we had about
guardians of galaxies I might have
changed it but um it just doesn't seem
as important as my top two it feels like
of all these it might it has the best
shot of being like a standalone story
yes and that's what I think James Gunn
is also doing because this is farewell
it's a close Zone yeah it's a closer so
how will it Ripple affect the rest of
the MCU in this phase or the next phase
or what we might not really see a lot of
those ripples now or because it is so
self-contained now hearing you I would
have definitely switched these things oh
okay I would have definitely switched
this but I'm going to stick with my list
was from the beginning and my number two
is Captain America New World Order
because I think there's so many
characters in this that we're gonna have
to give them each a little time to talk
about themselves and what they're gonna
affect the phase five overall in phase
six and again if there's going to be two
government kind of movies I think this
one's going to be more important than
the Thunderbolts
um but
don't cover me and my number one is like
that quantumania we did get a trailer
but I think since Kang is like what
we're expecting to end the phase six
with the next next phase I think it's
like okay he's introduced in this is the
first movie of phase four that he's
gonna be introduced in it's very
important I think Modoc is a very big
character too need to be important and
then that will get us ready for Captain
America new order if we bring Modoc into
here to miss with the leader and so
forth okay wow very interesting yours is
almost in like release horror yours is
almost in I'm gonna I'm just what I
don't know why the Violet okay so I was
just dropping but it's just koi is so
cute that I have to face
when you see a puppy so cute you must
kill it yeah it feels great all right
what is that that's a feeling that's a
real thing this uh this is hard for me
to say because this is something I'm
very excited you start from the bottom
so yeah yeah okay I think we're on the
same page of like we're all stoked over
at every one of these movies I'm going
to love all of them yes this pains me to
do but I'm gonna go Thunderbolts first
okay why is it paying you and actually
it's actually going to be before it's
actually nothing really sick this
movie's been canceled oh no I gotta
leave room for Deadpool oh so all right
so we got okay we got Thunderbolts uh
the reason it's so low is just because I
feel like it might be one of those
movies that feels like a bridge between
movies I feel like after Captain America
and before something the thunderbolt's
gonna have to do a lot of heavy lifting
this is the only movie I'm a little
worried about having to be too many
things uh so I'm just this is
such a new entity for General audiences
exactly okay it has a lot to do and that
always worries me also uh I do think
that it's a movie that as of now with
the current team is a lot of super
soldiers and I'm really curious how that
works in a team Dynamic when our team
movies have all had very Diverse Power
sets yeah so when I know they're going
to bring in a bummer
but for now for now as a press I want to
be near the puppy
uh and then we got uh the next up is
going to be similarly because of the
same reasons
uh I'm gonna go with New World War I
know and this one's interesting and it's
actually because of expectations of
other films my favorite non-spider Man
Captain America uh Marvel film is
Captain America Winter Soldier uh this
has the highest Stakes for me because I
feel like this is a direct sequel to
Winter Soldier and that is the hardest
thing to do so my fear is that my my
brain won't be able to go like winter
soldier so it was a civil war movie in
between caps but it didn't feel like uh
it didn't feel like an Espionage
Thriller I got you again like it didn't
feel like this to me feels like they're
making another Espionage Cat movie and
my fear is that Imma Be they could be
making a 90s professional wrestling
movie we don't know there's no trailer
yet frankly Captain America WCW but
again very very excited these are higher
than anything else really that year so
keep that in mind uh and then next up
this was the uh I think I've got this
pretty high comparatively uh this is a
movie that I think will solve a lot of
the Marvel humor problem that people
have at phase four uh I think that
Marvel when it's done right is exactly
the amount of humor you want for an
action movie I think a buddy cop body
humor movie is perfect like you can do a
lot of body swap humor you can do a lot
of Freaky Friday goodness question no I
I'm I'm I I'm so excited for the Marvels
I can't explain it so I don't not only
is it something that I think all the
people are like don't ask me a joke
every five minutes this movie can but
also be plot driven it's also a great
way to introduce three incredible women
as what I think is gonna be a more
authentic version of their characters I
think kamalakon is exactly kamalakon we
didn't get enough of spectrum or
whatever she might end up being one
division to know her and I feel like
Brie Larson didn't get to play the
Captain Marvel she is so this is like
the Redemption movie for both humor
these women in it and I think it's gonna
be huge for curry scroll war and I think
the visuals of this are going to be
bananas I think this is the movie that's
going to surprise people more than
anything else this is the biggest like I
think surprise for people who who wrote
Captain Marvel
um it was a I think it was oh I know one
of the writers was also
um a writer on the first Guardians of
the Galaxy before James Gunn came in and
wrote oh like yeah I think I wanna
there is a lot of things
the first Captain Marvel but also I want
to say her name is is it uh Pearlman is
she the person who Ron Perlman
no Story
by worked on the first Captain Marvel I
think we're coming down here appreciate
it great right by the Box okay and then
we got uh mine is not as recency biased
as maybe some other people but uh mine
is because uh Kang is going to be the
thing for uh 10 years uh Kang is going
to be our next Thanos the Kang is going
to be instrumental even if they bring in
Doctor Doom which I think they're gonna
do and Kang is kind of a one-two punch
with doom I do think Kang is gonna have
his own stronghold and then alley-oop
Doom as well but without him being as
strong as he needs to be Doom would
overshadow him That's How Strong he
needs to be here which I think is to
come and what we saw from he who remains
was one of the best villain performances
we've seen in Marvel and that wasn't
even his villain Arc yet like he was not
a villain he was a man that knows about
the concept of what he becomes that was
a man delivering Shakespeare this is the
first Marvel movie since they kind of
squandered Red Skull since Thanos
definitely have a Shakespearean villain
this is a villain that can withstand 10
movies this is a villain that can be for
the rest of time plus we have
potentially Scott Lang dying plus we
have those visuals this would be number
one if not four
Okay so Guardians of the Galaxy I think
could be the best Trilogy in the MCU a
lot of people don't like Guardians too
those people are wrong what uh the magic
of Guardians is that it is a drama
cosmic space comedy about characters
that shouldn't work on film Guardians of
the Galaxy is the first film that I was
like Disney bought them they want to
sell Rocket Raccoon toys in this tree
and then the movie came out and I was
like I was cynical and judgmental and
completely wrong I think the heart of
the MCU is the Guardians films and I
think we're about to have our heart
ripped out and chewed and that's going
to be amazing and I'm ready to suffer
because I think if phase four was about
like catharsis this is going to be about
things you can't save and what lost
feels like when it can't be solved I
think this is going to be what wakanda
forever was but with with not having a
button like what kind of forever was us
all healing this is about us all losing
this should have been in phase four
because phase four is what's love or
what's great but love persevering oh
this should have been in Facebook
I should have wrapped up not I blame it
I think but I think the closure of phase
four being about here yeah it's healthy
this is going to be about not healing
yeah I think this is going to be about
just the bounce what if the movie
the movie is
Circle reintroducing himself to a new
version of Gamora and almost rekindling
what was once lost until he's killed oh
my God
okay
take us home uh Reveal Your lineup what
has been coined the spiciest and or most
controversial of the rankings yeah I
don't know how that ended up happening
but I'm so excited for all of these
movies and one of the things I'm very
excited about is thunderbolts I have it
here mainly because like I think we've
kind of talked about they haven't told
us more of it yet once the movie comes
out once we actually can discuss the
spoilers and everything I think it'll be
kind of a different experience but for
right now this is I guess where my where
I think it's well I don't know where I
think it's ultimately gonna land is is
is somewhere in there next up I have oh
spices of the Galaxy vol 3 is is out of
everybody here I have it lowest ranked
and I'll tell you why whoops
didn't mean to do that uh we just
watched the holiday special from James
Gunn yeah we just recently watched The
Suicide Squad Peacemaker which I thought
was brilliant and then Gunn knocked out
those amazing Guardians one in two films
which I think two is also great but I
also think that James Gunn is a very
specific director and writer meaning
people either Vibe with what he's
selling or they don't I don't think it
has anything to do with quality I think
it just really like he's the type of
Storyteller that like it comes down to
preference because I think that
objectively speaking he is a good and
talented writer director and when people
say I didn't like this I thought it was
dumb that Peter Quill dance at the end
of Guardians of the Galaxy when I'm like
that's your preference but it perfect it
worked perfectly because the entire time
he was talking about the hero Kevin
Bacon like at all he knows what he's
doing but I also feel that with all of
these projects this is the one that we
may understand what we're getting before
we get it the most because we've seen
James Gunn's previous work we know these
characters so I feel as though it's
gonna land there people are gonna love
it for what it is but it's not
necessarily going to be like this
earth-shattering like it's a game
changer within the MCU it's the closer
of what we're very used to and what many
of us love very much myself included
next up we've got for all the reasons
y'all said
oh whoops this needs to be attached to
this Hector there we go uh the Marvels I
really liked what koi said so I'm just
going to just point go around it a
little bit look at what he said because
I think yeah
um next up
for those not watching live I have boom
along with Jess highest ranked Captain
America New World Order I also think
that this is going to be an incredibly
special movie and I just want to point
out that like we were mentioning some of
the writers and directors on these
projects I'm really excited that um that
Malcolm Spellman is also one of the
writers on this and he was the writer or
head writer of the Falcon in the Winter
Soldier miniseries which I loved what it
was able to delve into and I'm very
excited that some of that is probably
going to find its way into the frankly
the black Captain America movie we have
to talk about that and it's gonna it's
gonna address that and that series was
incredibly impacted by kovid even you
loved it and yes it was probably a shell
of what it could have been exactly right
absolutely and so this yes he will not
be held back yeah
the leader Samuel Stearns is going to be
in it not to mention that it may tie
into I think it could tie into the
Intelligentsia the She-Hulk all that
kind of stuff but more more more than
that I think Anthony Mackey is a movie
star and I think his Sam Wilson is so
great and I think that this project
could be that type of Winter Soldier
right Chris Evans as Steve Rogers that
amazing action adventure Espionage
Thriller but with the addedness of now
here's the perspective of these black
storytellers talking about the
experience of being a black man in the
United States and being Captain America
and all that on top of that so that's
why I have cap ranked as high as I do
and my number one I want to say not
because of Regency bias but because
Ant-Man in the wasp quantumania and I'll
tell you why really quickly it boils
down to this full disclosure I know the
writer of this movie he is a pal of mine
his name is Jeff loveness and Jeff was
the head writer of Jimmy Kimmel Live the
Jeff lovedness he was a head writer of
Jimmy Kimmel for years
um he uh he worked on Rick and Morty
which I think that Marvel recently
pulled a bunch of people from Rick and
Morty to work across a bunch of their
different things which is really great
and you need that kind of Rick and Morty
nerdy uh sci-fi writers to tackle things
like the Multiverse to try to really
make it all work
um but also Jeff has written some of my
favorite comics of all time and they
were Marvel stuff and DC stuff and I
love telling the story but Jeff is a guy
that I met when I first moved to Los
Angeles 10 some years ago and the story
I tell is it was like a house party or
something and I met him and his
roommates and and it ended up being that
me and Jeff were in the corner Talking
to Ourselves about why the X-Men were
awesome and Jeff was selling me on why
Cyclops was the best X-Men character
that's the type of guy that's the type
of guy that is and I'm not saying this
is this is you know uh he also was
recently announced as being the writer
of Avengers the Kang Dynasty so I want
to point out Kang is being introduced in
this movie this movie had to do well
enough as a final product that Marvel
Studios went hey guy who wrote this
continued to write that's our dude
continue to write Kang and on an
Avengers scale on an Avenger scale bring
in all the other characters Jeff wrote I
wanna I wanna highlight this too and I
want to uh if you haven't checked out
some of his comic work go read it he
wrote a crossover from Marvel years ago
that was Sam Wilson Captain America
Peter Parker Spider-Man in the Inhumans
and he has Peter Parker the way he
writes Peter Parker Peter says some
stuff that like defined the character
for me it like re-contextualized a an
aspect of Peter effing Parker who is a
character everybody knows in inside and
out and he wrote something that I was
like oh my God that's amazing Jeff's
favorite DC character I think unless I'm
misspeaking is Lois Lane that's the kind
of comic book nerd he is that's the kind
of guy he is that he's very familiar
with his characters he loves these
characters to that level I'm not saying
he's going to debut Scott summer Cyclops
in Avengers
he's the guy that everybody loves
Wolverine everybody loves Spider-Man
everybody loves you know Captain America
and the Avengers but he was the guy that
was like let me tell you about Cyclops
and I went you're my people and that's
in modern day it's a hard thing to walk
and he knows Cyclops is like a tricky so
so just based on Jeff loveness alone I'm
going quantumania is going to be
incredibly special and it's gonna be
that it's that perfect combination of
he's an incredibly talented writer who's
already had a lot of success in
Hollywood but on like beneath that
surface he is the guy who knows and
understands Marvel
um that to to the level that I'm just so
excited that he gets to be in the room
and making some calls and he was on the
set and rewriting as they're working and
making the movie together so that's why
I got quantumania at number one
we did kind of make this quantitative
and we assigned Point values to
everybody's list and then we did a an
accumulation list kind of like when you
put together all of our lists
um and so the the final list when you
when you account for all of our points
yeah
um the lowest movie Thunderbolts uh
pretty disrespectful in my opinion
um then then the Marvel's The New World
Order Guardians and quantumania one and
two uh quantumania was of course
everybody's either number one or number
two film we're all extremely excited for
that can I say one thing you absolutely
can this is my one thing I'm gonna say I
love the Marvels I know I put them
second from the bottom but I just want
to say I'm so in love with the marbles
they've been my wallpaper since they did
their prints since they've done
and I think everybody said like we're
not down on any of these movies it's
it's like fractions between five of
these and we hope we're surprised and
like have some happy surprises I just
want to throw out we have a couple
minutes or throw out a couple
hypotheticals somebody I think already
mentioned blade was originally scheduled
to be the sixth the movie in in Phase
five uh now it's probably gonna get
delayed to phase six uh winter of 2024
we assume yeah
um Hector where would you put blade
sorry Jeff it would have been my number
one
only because again I'm also thinking
about like if each of these movies when
they come out whatever their Rotten
Tomatoes score is right that's like a
really cheap and easy way to quantify
the overall kind of quality or like
critics impact all that other stuff I
think that that might be the sort of but
I think Thunderbolts might get like an
84 on Rotten Tomatoes and Guardians are
gonna get like an 87 you know that's
where I'm thinking I think blade might
come out with like a really really
strong
we talked about yesterday the amount of
work that they're putting into it the
commercial is going this isn't good
enough oh so Marshall uh yeah does he
have two Oscars
could we see green book and Moonlight
yeah yes when are we going to see an
actor be win an Oscar for a Marvel film
Deadpool three I got two Deadpool three
two jackets okay yeah so so the other
movie that is coming in phase six yeah
but you know right on the heels of phase
five Deadpool which was announced after
we got both both slates all right you're
number one you know what I mean starting
the board uh yeah I think uh
I want to briefly mention blade also
yeah for me blade would be probably uh
right after Quantum Mania uh so like at
three but only because right now I just
realized in this moment this is all what
I know the most about too so when I was
giving you crap about recency buys I've
seen the Guardians trailer twice I've
seen the quantumania trailer the most
I've seen the Marvels I haven't seen the
world or Thunderbolts what's tricky
about blade is the reason I can't put it
higher is much like New World Order I
love the first blade more than most
things in life yes so my expect stations
of it are going to be different than my
than my expectations of thunderbolts
like when I walk into blade I'm gonna
have to go like remember it's not Wesley
and that's going to be hard I love
rehearsala where would uh blade and
Deadpool fit for you in your ranking
Blaze my number one whoa number one it's
getting into the underworld and now that
we're getting into so much of the
underworld I'm like I'd rather hold on
to that more than I would king you think
man thing will make an appearance yes
where is
um
Deadpool
Deadpool three Deadpool kills the Marvel
Universe Deadpool and Wolverine versus
kind of yeah
number six the very bottom under the
Guardians of the Galaxy
and then real quick lightning round
um yeah I don't know it's it's uh it's
all a Gula you better play you know what
I mean I would not have blade number one
but I can't put it number one I don't
know here okay lightning round I was
about to see what else but lightning
around because we gotta wrap up name
your because one thing we don't have for
any upcoming phases are special
presentations yes it's kind of just
sneaking these in
um you know maybe tagging them on to
like with guardians with like a full
film shoot hey how about we give you an
extra week you want you to sneak an hour
uh now you're talking about special
presentation
baby how do I how do I uh make a dollar
out of 15 cents um but uh name what you
think could be a special presentation in
Phase five phase five okay not six I
honestly think you go first I got two
yeah Fourth of July Eli Bradley uh after
we've already are setting back up uh
Carl and we go into the New World Order
world I want to see Young Avengers have
his own movie have the Patriot get his
time to shine and my second one uh I
would do it early and I would do it uh
actually you know early in the year but
late in this phase like February next
year uh I think the only X-Men that I
I'm demanding gets their own is we
should have had a storm Solo movie and I
think that storm has the most cinematic
origin so I'd love to see her as a child
in Africa discovering her powers being
worshiped as a god before she has
anything to do with mutants I want to
see Aurora Monroe get time before she's
like even brought into that world and I
don't think you can do that in a movie
so I think you need to do that in a
special okay Jessica what's your special
presentation my special presentation is
only because I need to learn more about
them is Thor's New Daughter because
she's the first person that was born
after after from that creation and I'm
like what does she have she might be the
most powerful person on the planet right
now and I'm scared of her and I want to
see what she's about okay Hector now I'm
trying to go off of like well pick a
special presentation that's like
attached to a film shoot and that's
difficult for me to do looking at these
I'm going I don't know if I would give
any of these guys a special presentation
I'm also thinking holidays because
they've done that so far that's why I'm
thinking Fourth of July Halloween
Fourth of July no I don't know what
other bacon said Easter but I'm like I
don't know about that and then the post
credit holiday special Mall Rats yeah
I'm gonna say as a kind of a out of left
field I don't know if it'll be phase
five but maybe phase six I'm gonna say
Nova specifically Sam Alexander because
I think you keep Rocket Raccoon because
it's easier to pay Bradley Cooper to do
the voice for a CG character than it is
to keep actors and makeup and all that
and if you go to the Nova Sam Alexander
Comics his origin includes a special
appearance by Rocket Raccoon and Gamora
at the foot of his bed in the middle of
the night telling him what the hell the
Nova Corps is and then he's off to an
Adventure so I think Gamora coming
coming back I think Zoe Saldana would do
that and do and especially because he's
a Latino superhero that that's a way you
coax Zoe to come back into the makeup is
be like it's a special presentation we
know but major leading Latino young
character we're gonna put him on the
Young Avengers we're gonna you know Nova
Sam Alexander let's do it about uh
Dracula being blade and like that that's
as the villain I'd love to see Dracula
first do it on Easter because he's back
Easter Easter Easter instead of
Halloween
um because I think I I have two reasons
for that a Ghostwriter Halloween there's
a nice natural fit there a character
that
um because they probably want to bring
back at some point right we're gonna do
a midnight Suns or something like that
we're bringing black Brack we're
bringing back blade I almost said we're
bringing Black Blade which is wow
Tommy's not even here
to uh the Black Knight and the ebony
blade or whatever but um uh and here's
the thing uh I'm I'm overreading into
Bob iger's comments about Disney plus
and about how they don't they want to
chase profitability rather than
subscriber growth okay and I think my
interpretation of that is they are going
to focus on Marvel viewer tension rather
than attracting new subscribers and they
think like well you know what's going to
get people jazzed we all loved werewolf
by night everyone put words in your
mouth but I think it's Universal
approval rating is very high justice
agrees no no no I don't care she loved
it keep going and I think I think most
people dug the holiday special
um I think like
sneaking in I mean a ghost if you told
me next Halloween a Ghost Rider uh
special presentation was coming I'm
jazzed today how about this how about
this Marvel Studios a special
presentation ghost writers
is black Tom Cassidy bring me on my boys
I am Groot season two yeah give me that
holiday about trees uh thank you
everybody by the way for sending in
super chats uh Chef moyardi I love your
name uh Christian unpronounceable thank
you Joel uh Ralston Ralston iron oh
those people were yesterday um Chef
boyardee's name in real life is his
first name is Hector oh last name
Boyardee he's a real Chef absolutely
there's a man yeah was he known for him
it's in the Laura actually he was known
for his cans
um but thank you all for watching thank
you uh thank you Hector Jessica Coy for
being here today uh we appreciate you
for watching we'll be back uh tomorrow
and Friday wrapping up this week in fact
we might get into uh we've got some
really fun end of year stuff planned uh
for this week and the next two weeks
we'll recap some phase four stuff we
might even kind of do we did today but
for the series at Phase five uh holiday
party plans all kinds of fun stuff so
stick around like And subscribe this
video uh we appreciate you
bye
[Music]
thank you